one has to spend so many years in
learning to be happy
every year strips us of at least one
vain expectation
and teaches us to reckon some solid good
in its stat
i think that if you had asked me whether
i
thought this was on track this george
eliot quote
saying that we have to spend many years
and learning to be happy i think if
you'd asked me that when i was a younger
person i probably would have liked most
younger people and said
no that's bunk i'm pretty happy now or
at least i have some idea of what it
means to be happy
and i think that elliot is actually
correct that it it's it's the experience
and not just
accumulating experience in the sense of
you know suggestiousness or
learning about how things work but the
experience of suffering
and having to think about why in fact
we are unhappy rather than being a being
happy what it is that we're disappointed
by
uh where we went wrong i think all of
that
that sort of reflection goes into
allowing us to actually
find our way to to more lasting more
genuine happiness
i think that a lot of times we embrace
serious types of happiness as well and
turn out not to be all that happy
sometimes forcing ourselves to
try to appear or feel happy as a result
so you know this notion that every year
strips of us
at least one vain expectation and
teaches us to reckon some solid good and
instead
what that's talking about is becoming
more realistic not in the sense of just
lowering your expectations but becoming
realistic
by saying that is a real good this over
here that was only an apparent good
and i may have you know pitched my wagon
to that star but i can unhitch it and i
can
now hitch it to this one over here or
just let it sit still
there is a wonderful mythical law of
nature that the three things we crave
most in life
happiness freedom and peace of mind
are always attained by giving them to
someone else
this quotation by peyton conway march
this this is a really fascinating one
that gives
us a lot to think about the three things
that we crave
most in life happiness freedom and peace
of mind which interpenetrate each other
but are distinct they're different from
each other freedom and happiness
often don't go hand in hand sometimes
they're irreconcilable depending on your
notions of them
peace of mind and happiness are not
exactly the same thing either in peace
and mind
peace of mind and freedom don't always
align
with each other as a matter of fact
sometimes
you know we really only enjoy our
freedom when we're placed in situations
where we don't have
peace of mind where we couldn't have
peace of mind
be that as it may we do desire happiness
and what this quote is
talking about and what i really like
about it is that it's saying
we don't get to have that on our own
there's a lot of people who imagine
happiness to be something that they
would have
totally on their own and if
everybody else would just go away or
everybody else would be subject to them
genuine happiness comes through some
sort of
integration with others it doesn't have
to be the whole world the whole universe
but there do have to be some others with
whom
one shares things with with whom one can
live in a kind of harmonious existence
so that
you know if we work towards the
happiness of
others not necessarily all others maybe
maybe
more you know those who are grateful for
it and appreciative of it than those who
are ungrateful
we work for their happiness their peace
of mind
and their freedom
that's one of the conditions for
allowing us to fully experience those
as well if to enjoy
even an enjoyable present we must have
the assurance of a happy
future we are crying for the moon if
then we cannot live happily without an
assumed future
we are certainly not adapted to living
in a finite world where
despite the best plans accidents will
happen and where death comes at the end
so with this quote from alan watts um
you know there's really no surprise
there if you know much about
watts and his his own spiritual journey
uh through comparative religion
i do like what he's saying here that we
we have to
adapt ourselves to living in a finite
world even if we think that there are
openings to something exceeding the
world something transcendent
the world of our experience is a finite
one and if we invest it with
infinite demands infinite wishes
infinite
desires we're bound to be disappointed
um that's not to say that that other
people in the world aren't
you might say points of infinity but
they have to be sort of opened up
and you can't force them to do that they
have to be allowed to do that
to use a word that watts you know liked
quite a bit and and many people of his
generation did
organically so
a lot of us are looking for security and
imagine
that happiness and security are
intimately connected
that we can assure ourselves of
happiness
and as creatures in
a a world of finitude that's not going
to be
possible to us especially a world of
finitude that we don't fully
grasp we don't fully understand we're
not god
after all so in order to live happily
we have to i don't want to just say
embrace the moment or something like
that as if
we don't have any past we don't have any
future
but we have to be willing to say
i don't need to control everything
i was thinking this morning how on earth
it came that i
was fond of talking and i'm scarcely out
of spirits
should so entirely rest my notions of
happiness on quietness and a good deal
of solitude
during the last five years of my voyage
which from the active manner in which
they have been passed may be said to be
the commencement of my real life
the whole of my pleasure was derived
from what passed in my mind
whilst admiring views by myself
i think that you will humanize me and
soon teach me there is greater happiness
than in building theories and
accumulating facts in silence and
solitude
i very much like this this quotation by
charles darwin who's writing to his wife
emma while he's still in the middle of
his his journeys
he's contrasting a couple different
notions
of happiness that are that are coming
through
anticipation coming through experience
and he's being very uh reflective and
he's showing us
uh you know that he's very much a man of
his his times intellectually
you know we tend to think of darwin and
the word we associate immediately is
evolution and theory but you know we
forget the fact that this guy was kind
of an adventurer in a way
as many of these these uh these
explorers
you know like scientists um great
theoreticians were
he's traveling around the world on a
ship and he's
you know he's experiencing nature in
ways that
very often we ourselves don't have
access to because you know it's a
different century
that he's inhabiting we have to do a lot
of work to get get away from
uh modern technology he had to bring it
with him
and so he's you know he's exposed to
these wonderful
immense landscapes um seascapes as well
and he he takes pleasure in that
happiness for him
he talks about it at first happiness
occurs for him in solitude why does it
occur in solitude because he is on his
own
enjoying the natural landscape but also
enjoying the life of the mind
accumulating facts as he says
working out and contemplating theories
now notice then what he's saying to this
this woman
who he hopes to enjoy wedded bliss with
he says
you're going to humanize me you're going
to reveal to me
something more about the human and i
don't think it's just sort of romantic
claptrap you know sentimentalism he
recognizes that
to really be happy in a higher sense
it has to be in relationship or perhaps
even in
in some sort of community with other
other beings other
people and for us human beings
animals and nature however
great it can be however fascinating just
doesn't cut it
so he says you're going to teach me
there's a greater happiness
and i like that that notion
a clear horizon nothing to worry about
on your plate
only things that are creative and not
destructive
when all of these negative emotions are
removed and you can look forward and the
road is clear ahead
and now you're going to create something
i think that's as happy as i'll ever
want to be
so i'm finishing up here with a
quotation
that was brought to my attention by by
an old friend
and colleague years ago who himself
very much likes like uh hitchcock and
his movies and then his
sentiments and art and i really like
this as well hitchcock was
um sort of you know unassuming
guy he put himself into a lot of his
movies as that guy was bumbling around
over there
you know as a bit shot and
what he's saying here is is really
fascinating
a clear horizon nothing to worry about
on on your plate
only things that are creative and not
destructive and then
he i left a bit of that quote out but
he's talking about negative emotions and
how
although people don't realize that he's
quite sensitive and
will will dwell on somebody you know
giving him a
cutting look or saying a mean thing to
him
and so this this creative not
destructive
you know positive not negative
it's not just i want to be free i don't
want to be bothered by people
he like many creative people wants to be
able to concentrate on
his art he wants to be able to
concentrate on the processes
of creative production which involves a
lot of
a lot of thinking involves a lot of
pondering a lot of
hoping for the happy moment a lot of
putting in the time
so that things can align right and you
can grasp
something and say aha now i've got it um
so he says you know what i like is a
clear
road and and i can fully understand that
you know a day when i get to to write
or even just to think about things
um you know and i get to put aside all
of the other
stuff that i have to worry about all the
preoccupations with other people's
needs desires you know
complaints there's a liberatory
force to that that feels extraordinarily
good
and so that is his picture of happiness
and that's what i'm going to leave you
with i've looked at these
five really quite different quotations
by by people who had interesting things
to say
about happiness i'm not saying that you
can synthesize all of these or
you know put them together in one
unified viewpoint i don't think that we
need to
but i think that as we're moving into
this
happiness happens month it's a good idea
for us to to look at what what
brilliant people have had to say on the
nature of happiness
and to reflect on it ourselves and you
know really mull it over and say is
there something to this or not
what else does that make me think about